>> Katie: I DID NOT PICK THE
SONG.
MAXINE WATERS IS UNHINGED.
SHE'S DOUBLING DOWN ON CALLS FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO BE THROWN IN
PRISON OVER UKRAINE.
WHEN ASKED, SHE DEFENDED HER
COMMENTS.
>> I THINK MOST PEOPLE WHO'VE
WALKS ME OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
KNOW THAT I'M A RESPONSIBLE
PERSON WHO HAS TALKED ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION.
THEY KNOW THAT I'VE BEEN SERIOUS
ABOUT THIS.
I'VE HAD THE COURAGE TO STAND UP
WHEN NOBODY ELSE WOULD STAND
WITH ME.
PEOPLE KNOW I AM RESPONSIBLE AND
THAT I'M SERIOUS AND LIKE I SAI
SAID, IMPEACHMENT IS THE
IMPERATIVE.
>> Katie: TRY TO FIGURE THIS
OUT.
AFTER SAYING THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE BEHIND BARS, WATERS IS
CLAIMING IT'S TRUMP WHO IS
PUTTING HER IN DANGER.
>> HE'S THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HE IS SETTING SAWS UP TO BE
KILLED.
I HAVE DEATH THREATS CONSTANTLY.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN CONVICTED,
THREATENING TO KILL ME.
I CAN'T GO TO THE GROCERY STORE
ANYMORE BY MYSELF.
I HAVE TO PAY FOR SECURITY.
I CAN'T MOVE AROUND THE COUNTRY
WITHOUT SECURITY.
>> Katie: THIS IS THE SAME
WOMAN WHO SAID TRUMP CABINET
MEMBERS SHOULD BE HARASSED IN
PUBLIC.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT IRONIC TO HEAR
HER COMPLAINING.
>> Jesse: NO ONE WANTS A CIVIL
WAR.
I THINK THE REPUBLICANS ARE
UNDEFEATED IN CIVIL WARS, JUST A
REFRESHER FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
FORGOT.
MAXINE WATERS, NO RELATION.
I KNOW HER PRETTY WELL.
I UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE BOOK
HER.
SHE'S CRAZY.
AND OCCASIONALLY YOU NEED TO
BOOK CRAZY PEOPLE ON CABLE SO
KEEP THE AUDIENCE INTERESTED
BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT
SHE'S GOING TO SAY.
>> Greg: IT'S EVERYBODY NAMED
WATERS.
>> Jesse: VERY UNPREDICTABLE.
THEY PUT HER ON MSNBC AND LET
HER GO AND WHO KNOWS WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
ALAN GRAYSON, PEOPLE LIKE THAT.
CRAZY PEOPLE.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO, THE CRAZY
PEOPLE HAVE THREE CARDS.
THE RACE CARD, THE GENDER CARD,
THE DEATH CARD.
THE DEATH CARD USED TO BE
REPUBLICAN POLICIES KILLED
PEOPLE.
REPEALING OBAMACARE IS GOING TO
KILL YOU, ALL OF THAT STUFF.
REPUBLICAN RHETORIC WILL KILL
YOU NOW.
BUILD THE WALL WILL GET PEOPLE
KILLED.
WHATEVER.
IT GETS EVERYBODY KILLED.
THIS IS WHY THEY DO THAT.
THEY TRY TO TEE IT UP SO THE
NEXT TIME THERE'S VIOLENCE IN
THE COUNTRY, THEY CAN BLAME
TRUMP.
THEY ALSO DO THIS TO MAKE
THEMSELVES FEEL BETTER ABOUT
THEMSELVES, LIKE THEY ARE SO
IMPORTANT THAT THEY MIGHT
ACTUALLY GET KILLED.
I GET DEATH THREATS ALL THE TIME
AND I'M A WONDERFUL PERSON.
>> Greg: FROM THE ESPECIALLY
VARIED >> Jesse: IT CREATES
FEAR AND THE ELECTORATE, THAT
TRUMP IS SO DANGEROUS HE CAN'T
AFFORD A SECOND TERM AND YOU
CAN'T CRITICIZE ME BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO KILL ME.
>> Katie: GREG, HOW DO YOU
FEEL ABOUT ABRAHAM LINCOLN?
>> Greg: INTERESTING QUESTION.
HE WAS A GOOD GUY.
A LITTLE TOO TALL FOR MY TASTES.
INTERESTING BACK STORY THAT I
WON'T GET INTO.
MAXINE SYMBOLIZES THE HYPOCRISY
OF THE ENTIRE LEFT IN THE MEDIA
IN GENERAL.
ONLY WE, THE MEDIA, CAN BE
HOSTILE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SHARE THE
BALL.
I HAVE SAID THIS BEFORE.
I'M TIRED OF SAYING IT.
THEY OWN THE FIELD.
THE ONLY REFS, THE EQUIPMENT.
HOW DARE TRUMP SHOW UP AND BEAT
THEM AT THEIR OWN GAME.
REMINDS ME OF ONE FOX NEWS
SHOWED UP AND EVERYONE WAS
SAYING OH, MY GOD, THIS
POLARIZATION.
YOU ONLY LIKED IT WHEN THERE WAS
ONE POLE.
YOU HAVE TO WORK HARDER TO
DEFEND YOUR BELIEFS AND THAT'S
THE PROBLEM.
AS FOR THE DEATH THREATS, WE ALL
GET THE DEATH THREATS.
IT'S PART OF THE GAME.
THERE'S A LOT OF CRAZY PEOPLE
OUT THERE AND THERE'S NEW
AVENUES TO GO AFTER PEOPLE.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
THE BAR IS LOW.
I THINK IT'S HEALTHY FOR BOTH
SIDES THAT THERE ARE NOW TWO
SIDES.
SHE CAN'T BE COMPLAINING.
>> Katie: DANA, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> Dana: I MENTIONED PELOSI
DEPUTIZING ADAM SCHIFF MIGHT NOT
BE THE BEST SOLUTION BUT IT
MIGHT BE BETTER THAN HAVING
MAXINE WATERS TALK ABOUT IT.
NANCY PELOSI IS TRYING TO BE
VERY MEASURED.
SHE PEPPERS HER COMMENTARY, WE
NEED TO BE THOUGHTFUL, PRAY FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
WORK ON THE WORK THAT PEOPLE
WANT, WORK ON THE TRADE DEAL,
INFRASTRUCTURE, GUN CONTROL.
LOWERING DRUG PRICES AND SHE
WANTS TO DO THOSE THINGS.
SHE'S GOING TO BE VERY MEASURED
AND THEN MAXINE WATERS SAYS
ACTUALLY HE SHOULD BE KILLED.
OR YOU SHOULD BE IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
THE ONE THING YOU HAVE TO WONDER
ABOUT, BEING A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS FOR THAT MANY YEARS AND
NO ONE TAKING YOU SERIOUSLY.
>> Katie: JUAN, DO YOU TAKE
MAXINE WATERS SERIOUSLY?
>> Juan: SHE WAS AHEAD OF THE
CURVE ON IMPEACHMENT.
YOU DON'T HEAR PEOPLE SAY THAT.
SHE WAS SAYING ALL ALONG THAT
THESE WERE IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES.
YOU SAID THAT BOOKERS LIKE TO
GET, I THINK WHAT YOU SAID WAS
CRAZY WHICH I THINK IS
OFFENSIVE.
I DON'T THINK THAT LADY IS
CRAZY.
>> Jesse: MAYBE SHE'S NOT
OFFICIALLY MENTALLY ILL.
>> Juan: SHE IS AN ELECTED
MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
UNLESS YOU ARE SAYING HER
VOTERS.
NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK YOUR DESCRIPTION.
>> Jesse: I CAN'T CALL HER
CRAZY?
>> Juan: AM I ALLOWED TO SPEAK
ON THIS SHOW?
YOU STATED THEY LIKE TO INVITE
PEOPLE LIKE HER ON.
THE LAST FEW DAYS I'VE HEARD
FROM ONE PERSON TALK ABOUT
CIVIL WAR, SPIES, TREASON,
SUGGESTIONS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE SOMEBODY EXECUTED,
PROFANITY AND ATTACKS.
IT SEEMS THAT TRUMP IS
PERFORMING.